- I wanted to be really successful,
but not to just, like, get shoes;
I knew I wanted to make money
because I wanted to make a difference.
Listen to your gut and your heart,
because, no matter what
any expert tells you,
your wisdom inside needs to be paramount.
When I was bartending,
I was fully bartending.
Like, I wasn't talking to myself about:
"Oh, my God, I should be
dancing right now," or,
"I should be working on
my coaching practice."
While I was growing my
personal coaching practice,
I kept feeling conflicted because
I didn't want to just be one thing.
Are you guys here because
you want to be mediocre?
- [Audience] No.
- Mediocre sucks, does it not?
Don't get taken over by the
world's definition of success.
It's like, everything that I've learned
and I've been able to do in my business,
we never know what's going to work.
You should just engage an experience
and actually get your
foot in the industry.
That can inform whether or
not you should move ahead.
I have been this way,
meaning goofy, silly,
since I was very, very little.
You walk around your day, and you're like,
"Wow, I have so many things
to do," and I'm like,
"Wait a minute. This is
all awesome stuff to do."
- She's an American life
coach, motivational speaker,
author, and YouTuber.
She's the owner and creator
of Marie Forleo International,
B-School, and MarieTV.
Forbes.com listed her website
as one of the top 100
websites for entrepreneurs.
She's Marie Forleo,
and here are her top
ten rules for success.
- You know, my first gig out
of college was on Wall Street,
on the New York Stock Exchange, and-
- [Interviewer] This is pre-?
- This is pre-everything.
This is like, just out of
college, twenty-one years old,
and I knew one of my drives:
I wanted to be really successful,
but not to just, like, get shoes.
I knew I wanted to make money
because I wanted to make a difference.
I wanted to be able to
take care of my family.
I wanted to be able to contribute
to causes that I believe in,
and so I knew, in order to do that,
in my own mind, I was like:
"Well, I want to make a lot of money
and make this stuff happen."
But, when I was on Wall Street,
even though so many
people that I worked with-
multi-multi-millionaires, I
mean, the money was ridiculous-
while they were financially rich,
they were spiritually bankrupt.
And I felt, like, there was a part of me
that was dying inside, and I said,
"This is not my path. I
don't know what my path is,
but I need to leave this
because I feel sick."
And so, I think many
people feel like that.
You can find yourself a
job, and job, and job,
and you want to do a really-
you want to do great work in the world,
you're giving it your best,
but some little voice inside
is saying "This isn't me."
- [Interviewer] Right.
- "This isn't me."
And I kept having that voice
until finally I left the corporate world
and started my own business.
- Listen to your gut, and your heart,
because, no matter what
any expert tells you,
your wisdom inside needs to be paramount.
It needs to always drive
all of your decisions.
Even, you know, when I
was first starting out,
I would pay attention to people
that absolutely knew what they were doing.
They were completely
ethical, they were smart,
they were good teachers as well.
Sometimes, their advice just
didn't sit right with me,
and if I wasn't as secure
in my own inner voice,
I might have gone down paths
that wouldn't have been that great.
So, I think it's wonderful
to get an education,
it's wonderful to take in experiences,
but never, ever, ever
listen to anything other
than what is that true voice within you,
and that takes practice.
- When I was bartending,
I was fully bartending.
Like, I wasn't talking to myself about:
"Oh, my God, I should be
dancing right now," or,
"I should be working on
my coaching practice."
I was just really into bartending,
and, when I was dancing,
I was like, you know,
being the best hip-hop
teacher/dancer I could possibly be.
When I was being a coach,
same kind of thing.
And I think that practice
of being fully engaged,
in the thing that you're doing,
conserves a ton of energy,
and that's what most people don't do.
- Part of what was also
challenging for me,
when I was starting off as a coach,
was recognizing the truth:
that I didn't just want to be a coach.
I loved writing, I loved hip-hop,
I loved dance, I loved fitness.
There were all these different things
that I was passionate about;
and, while I was growing my
personal coaching practice,
I kept feeling conflicted
because I didn't want
to just be one thing.
Has anyone ever felt that way?
- [Interviewer laughs.]
- Yeah. So, I would listen to the voices
in my head which were like-
and, basically, the voices
in my head were so trained
by traditional wisdom
and traditional thoughts about:
"You have to pick a niche.
You have to narrow down.
You have to choose one
thing and be good for it,
be really good at it, and
that's how you'll be known."
And, when I realized that
that voice wasn't the voice
that I should listen to,
that there was this truth:
that I was this multi-passionate person,
and that living in the present moment,
which Eckhart teaches,
was all about really listening
to your own inner guidance
and being in the here and now,
and not stressing so much up here.
That really opened the door for me to say,
"You know what? Screw it.
I'm going to go take dance classes.
I'm going to go learn about this.
I'm going to do all
these different things."
And that training, to be in the moment,
and to listen to my own inner guidance,
allowed me to disconnect from
all the B.S. voices in my head
that were torturing me.
Torturing me.
- How would you behave if you
were the best in the world
at what you do?
How would that change what time
you wake up in the morning?
How would that change the
food you put in your body?
people you hang out with?
How you spend your time
throughout the day?
What websites you visit?
Whether or not you work from a schedule?
If you were world class,
and the best in the world at what you do,
how would your behavior change?
It's a really interesting question
that I started asking
myself a few years ago,
and, I will tell you, it
has changed everything.
It's one of those singular questions;
whether you put it on your screensaver,
you have a little reminder
on your cell phone,
you have it on the top of a notebook;
I guarantee you, if you
start looking at your world
through this lens, it's
going to shift everything.
Now, let me ask you this,
just to back this up a little bit more:
are you guys here because
you want to be mediocre?
- [Audience] No.
- Mediocre sucks, does it not?
- [Audience] Yes!
- We want to be world-class.
We want to be the best,
and let me ask you this:
who's in charge of you
being the best in the world?
Yes? Can I hear an "I am?"
- [Audience] I am.
- A little louder?
- [Audience] I AM.
- One more?
- [Audience] I AM!
- Amen, and it's not even
a Sunday. Okay, good.
- If you had to give someone
who's recently graduating
from our program a piece of advice,
what would you say?
- I would say to learn and to
execute on your unique vision.
Define success for yourself.
Figure out what that means to you.
Don't get taken over by the
world's definition of success,
or your family's, or what
your friends are doing,
or what anyone says that equals success.
Once you can get clear on that vision,
then you need to create a plan
to make that come to life,
and to prioritize.
I think one of the biggest
tragedies of our time is:
I hear so many people
from every walk of life,
health coaches, all over,
feeling so overwhelmed, and overworked,
and there's so much that they can do,
that they feel paralyzed.
"Well, I don't know what to do first,"
"How do I make all of this happen,"
and I think that we all need
to take a few steps back
and start to get clear
on our own vision for success,
and then actually prioritize
making that come to life,
because then it gives you such
clarity, and such freedom;
and all of that static
and the overwhelm starts
to fall away.
- What if I actually follow my heart,
and I don't make a living at it?
All my friends say, "You
suck. See, I told you so?"
Eckhart actually talked about
when, he was moving once,
his parents said, "Really?
You're going to do this again?"
Like, they'd seen him
as a failure for years,
and then- anyways. There's
that, always that voice,
that's like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,"
but you might just really fail.
- Yeah, and, you know, I
think all of us have that,
and there's perhaps some
of them, like a myth,
that many of us can think,
especially when we're first starting out,
that successful people don't
have the voice anymore.
That's total crap.
Anyone that you've ever seen,
anyone that I've encountered,
and I've had the opportunity to interview
a lot of people and talk to them;
no matter how successful,
how accomplished,
how well-known, they still have
those voices of self-doubt.
They still get afraid.
They still question:
"Am I going in the right direction?
What's next for me?"
And, I think, the more
that we can recognize that
that voice of, basically,
"You suck," is universal,
and we can disengage from
that and actually engage
with what we want in our lives,
the happier we're going to be.
And, this is the other
thing: none of us know.
It's like, everything that I've learned
and I've been able to do in my business,
we never know what's going to work.
We treat every single
thing as an experiment.
That's the only way that you learn.
I think 99% of what each of us
need to do to learn and grow,
not only as businesspeople,
but also as human beings,
if we're going to grow,
it means that we've
never done that before.
It's going to be uncomfortable.
And, to be okay in that
uncertainty and that discomfort,
is where the juice of life lives.
- I really went into
pursuing different passions
with eyes wide open; meaning:
knowing, because my focus was split,
I probably wouldn't be getting
very far in any of them;
but I made a conscious
choice that I just wanted
to experience them.
I wanted to understand
them from the inside out.
I spent so much time thinking, in my mind,
"Is this the right choice for me?
Is this the right career for me?
Should I try to build a
business around this?",
and I said, "That's such a
dumb way to go around it."
Like, you should just
engage and experience
and actually get your
foot in the industry.
That can inform whether or
not you should move ahead.
- What about someone who's
stuck, or struggling?
What would you tell them?
- Stuck or struggling is typically someone
who is more engaged in their thoughts
than actually taking action.
So, it's a really
interesting, subtle shift;
but, if you catch
yourself complaining like,
"Oh, I'm so stuck, and-"
Stop.
Write an e-mail, make a call, take a step,
and the more you actually do that
and catch yourself, we actually-
Sorry, this is me, A.D.D., my
toes are exactly that color.
- Awesome.
- Yes.
- I love it.
- But it is.
It's really a practice of
checking in with yourself.
You got to check yourself
before you wreck yourself.
Like, stop complaining,
stop talking to yourself in your head,
and do something.
I have been this way,
meaning goofy, silly,
since I was very, very little.
And, when I first started
my coaching practice
when I was twenty-three,
I tried to be what I thought
in my mind was a "businesswoman".
I had this idea of, like, a power suit,
and some big old shoulder pads,
and I would speak in a certain way,
and I remember trying to do
that, and I felt horrible.
Like, I felt so stunted.
It was like I had writer's block.
I had speaker's block.
I just felt like I was
in somebody else's skin,
and it was so painful for
me that I was just like,
"I can't do this, but I
really want to do this thing.
I'm going to let go of my idea
of who I think I should be,
and talk about the fact I'm from Jersey,
I don't use proper language all the time,
I have kind of a weird sense of humor,
I love zombies, Smurfs,
all kinds of things,
and what would happen if I
actually just expressed that?"
And something funny
actually did happen, is:
not only did I find myself
to be more creative,
I found myself more fulfilled,
and people actually
connected with me more.
I didn't feel like I had to
push myself out into the world;
it was more like things
started to come to me.
And I didn't feel like there
was so much of a separation
between my "work day"
and the rest of my life,
which felt great.
For me, a good life is a couple of things.
One, being fully present in each moment,
because I find that, when
I am fully present, like,
you know, you and I having
this great conversation now,
or if I'm with Josh and
we're just hanging out.
It does not matter what we're doing,
but I feel so-
peaceful, and content,
and like all is well in the world.
Even if there's challenges,
I feel a sense of peace,
and that's one component of it;
and, I think the other component, for me,
of living a good life,
is having good friends
and having a lot of fun.
I think any time that I slip
into taking things too seriously;
like, you walk around in
your day, and you're like,
"Wow, I have so many things to do,"
and I'm like, "Wait a minute.
This is all awesome stuff to do,
and I set my life up this way.
I'd better not take it so seriously,
and have a little fun, and
put on some music and dance."
When that kind of thread of
celebration and irreverence
and not taking things too seriously-
That's what living a good
life feels like to me.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I made this video because
Ewelina asked me to;
so, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll join the discussion.
I'd also love to know which
of Marie's top ten rules
meant the most to you, and
had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion.
And, one last thing:
my personal goal is to hit
one million subscribers
on this channel, so anything
that you can think of
to share the video, tweet
it, add the playlist,
tell your friends about it,
I'd really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much!
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
- The fact that,
when you're good at
whatever you're good at;
so, for me, I was so
passionate about spirituality
and personal development,
and all of the tools that
come in that toolbox;
but recognizing you also have
to know how to run a business.
Being good at something
isn't the same thing as
being able to run a
business doing that thing.
And I recognized very
quickly that I needed
to understand how to market,
and I wanted to use these new online tools
specifically because I was so embarrassed
about my age because I was so young,
that I wanted to use the
internet, which I did,
to mask my age.
And I never lied, but I got headshots done
that made me look much older than I was,
and I put up a website,
and all of my clients came
to me through the internet;
and, if they didn't ask how
old I was, I didn't tell them.
I just did the best work I could.
But that key lesson about:
even if you love something,
and even if it's your passion,
you have to also get passionate
about entrepreneurship.
- [Interviewer] If you want
to make a living at it.
- If you want to make a living
at it as a solo entrepreneur,
as a business owner.
- Nothing will kill your business faster
than being lost in a crowd of sameys.
How many people here ever
feel like you look around,
and it's like: "Everybody's
doing the same shit!"
Right? Do you feel like that?
Everybody starts copying each other,
and it all starts to look the same,
and it all starts to sound the same,
so positioning is all about
positioning yourself
to be vastly different.
This is probably one of my favorite parts
of this presentation.
I'm going to teach you
something that is so damn good.
I promise, if you do this
for your whole business
and every product or service you have,
you'll be able to articulate
very, very clearly
exactly how you are different;
and, more importantly
than articulating it,
it's going to be a
living, breathing essence
of how you stand apart
from everybody else.
- I feel like I love
the process of learning and
discovering new things so much,
and I love seeing other people win.
So, like, learning these
new ideas and new skills
that I've never been exposed to before,
and then being able to
teach them to other people
and watch the ah-hah
moments or the breakthroughs
or the progress happen for them.
I love seeing other people win.
So that's what kept driving me,
and I was like:
"Wow, if I could do this with five people,
I could do this with, like, twenty people,
or a hundred people,
or a thousand people,"
and it was really exciting.